WELCOME BACK, THE BELARUSIAN
PRESIDENT ALEXANDER LUCIAN
SANGHA IS DISMISSING REPORTS OF
HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES SINCE HAS
DISPUTED REELECTION LAST YEAR.
HIS GOVERNMENT ALSO BEING
ACCUSED OF MIGRANTS AN EU
BORDER STATES AND RETALIATION
OVER WESTERN SANCTIONS.
KNOWN AS EUROPE'S LAST DICTATOR
HE HAS LED THE NATION FOR
NEARLY 3 DECADES AND AN
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH
MATTHEW CHANCE THE SHANK O SAYS
HE HAS NOTHING TO BE SORRY FOR.
WOULD >> YOU TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO APOLOGIZE TO
THE PEOPLE OF BELARUS FOR THE
HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES THAT THEY
SUFFERED AT YOUR HANDS?
>> [INTERPRETER]
NO, I WOULD NOT LIKE TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY.
I WOULD DO THAT THROUGH THE
BELARUSIAN MEDIA, WHAT WOULD BE
THE POINT OF DOING IT ON CNN.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A
RELEVANT QUESTION.
IN PRINCIPLE I HAVE NOTHING TO
APOLOGIZE FOR.
>> YOU SAY YOU HAVE NOTHING TO
APOLOGIZE FOR, BUT HUMAN RIGHTS
WATCH SAYS MULTIPLE DETAINEES
HAVE REPORTED BROKEN BONES,
BROKEN FEET, BRAIN INJURIES,
SKINNY MOMENTS, ELECTRICAL
BURNS.
AMNESTY INTERNATIONAL SPEAKS OF
DETENTION CENTERS BEING,
BECOMING TORTURE CHAMBERS,
PROTESTERS WERE FORCED TO LIE
IN THE DIRT, STRIPPED NAKED,
WHILE POLICE KICKED AND BEAT
THEM.
YOU DON'T THINK THAT IS WORTH
APOLOGIZING FOR?
>> [INTERPRETER]
YOU KNOW, WE DON'T HAVE A
SINGLE DETENTION CENTER AS YOU
SAY LIKE ONE TOM, OH OR THOSE
BASES THAT THE UNITED STATES
AND, YOUR COUNTRY CREATED IN
EASTERN EUROPE.
AS REGARDS TO OUR ONLY
ATTENTION CENTERS, WHERE WE
KEEP THOSE ACCUSED, OR UNDER
INVESTIGATION, THERE ARE NO
WORSE THAN IN BRITAIN OR THE
UNITED STATES.
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU THAT.
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> THE VIOLENCE OVER THAT
PERIOD HAS LEFT YOU IN THE EYES
OF MUCH OF THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY AS AN INTERNATIONAL
PRIOR, YOU ARE THE MAIN
OPPOSITION FIGURE IN THIS
COUNTRY, SVETLANA TOOK A --
IS REGARDED AS THE MAIN
INTERNATIONAL CIRCLES AS THE
TRUE WINNER OF THE ELECTION
LAST YEAR, THE ELECTED LEADER
PROPERLY OF BELARUS.
EVEN PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS MET
HER IN THE WHITE HOUSE, YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN INVITED TO THE
WHITE HOUSE HAVE YOU?
>> [INTERPRETER]
THE FEMALE PERSONA ARE NOT
GOING TO DISCUSS HER.
I DON'T FIGHT WITH WOMEN, AND I
DON'T WANT TO CHARACTERIZE HER
IN ANY WAY AS REGARDS TO
OPPOSITION LEADERSHIP, THE
LEADER OF THE OPPOSITION IS
SOMEONE WHO LIVES IN THIS
COUNTRY AND HAS A DIFFERENT
POINT OF VIEW.
THEY CAMPAIGN TO BRING THIS
ALTERNATIVE HERE TO FRUITION.
THERE ARE NO SUCH PEOPLE IN
BELARUS, THEY ARE SOMEWHERE
OVER THERE ON YOUR SIDE, PAID
BY.
YOU >> KNOW THEY FLED THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID
OF STAYING HERE, THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE STAYED HAVE BEEN
IMPRISONED, PUT IN JAIL FOR
10-11 YEARS BECAUSE OF THEIR
OPPOSITION ACTIVITIES.
YOU KNOW THAT'S THE CASE.
>> [INTERPRETER]
LOOK, IF ONE IS A REVOLUTIONARY
AND IT CAUGHT THEMSELVES
INVOLVED IN THE REVOLUTION.
MOREOVER TRIED TO WIN --
4 IN MONEY THEY NEED TO BE
PREPARED FOR ANYTHING.
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> WHAT ABOUT THE THREAT THAT
YOU ARE ACCUSED OF POSING NOW?
THE POLISH GOVERNMENT,
LITHUANIA GOVERNMENT, OTHERS,
SAYING YOU ARE ENCOURAGING
MIGRANTS FROM VARIOUS PARTS OF
THE WORLD TO TRAVEL TO BELARUS,
AND THEN PUSHING THEM TOWARDS
THE BORDERS OF THOSE COUNTRIES,
PUTTING MASSIVE PRESSURE ON THE
BORDER AUTHORITIES IN EUROPEAN
UNION STATES.
DO YOU TAKE FULL RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE REFUGEE CRISIS THAT IS
UNDERWAY ON THE BELARUSIAN,
EUROPEAN BORDERS AT THE MOMENT?
>> [INTERPRETER]
DO YOU HAVE ANY ACTUAL PROOF
TIME PUSHING THESE PEOPLE TO
THE BORDER?
NO YOU HAVE NONE, AND YOU
CANNOT HAVE IT.
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> WELL EUROPEAN GOVERNMENTS
SAY YOU ARE WEAPONIZING
MIGRANTS, YOU ARE DOING THAT --
AS AN ACT OF REVENGE, REVENGE
FOR EUROPEAN SANCTIONS, AND
THEN REVENGE FOR THE FACT THAT
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES ARE
SHELTERING YOUR DISSIDENTS.
HOW DO YOU ANSWER THAT
CRITICISM?
>> [INTERPRETER]
ARE YOU TAKING ME FOR A MAD MAN?
MY COUNTRY IS IN CENTRAL EUROPE,
IT IS A SMALL ONE.
A FEW MILLION PEOPLE CANNOT
DICTATE TERMS TO HALF A
BILLION.
I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE TERMS ON
ANYONE.